welcome to the next level right now I'm
here with my guy all the way from
Detroit and the heart of the city alum
I'm talking about Jeff horse named
gentle give us some love let's talk
about Detroit man you know you play
shows with black audiences what
adjustments do feel like you have to
make if any really I think it was just
because it wasn't the black audiences as
much as just some of the rooms in
Detroit were just harder rooms so
performance I love so it I just put a
funnier joke up top hey you go then I
did my set as normal it wasn't really it
wasn't a change that was those are the
jokes that I enjoy telling I love that
and finally I had an audience that
understood them more cuz it man
it shouldn't matter funny it's funny all
right well you know what right now I
want to learn some stuff about you from
looking at a photo
okay here's just seeing your high school
picture Jeff did me favorite man uh
explained what was going on here Freeza
you see I grew facial hair at a very
young age he looks older than you now
yeah you look like a detective doesn't
he look like an undercover cop you just
look like you're wearing a wire wool was
one of the strangest experiences that
you had I've had a few I performed in
nudist colonies since I left I have
booked to perform in a nudist colony
Michael walk-up stop first right first
of all who's booking this gear not not
that I want to go but if there's a
promoter who who am I get in touch with
about the news you I want to be
mentioned damn naked people and I saw
yeah yeah yeah literally literally it
you're doing stand-up uh-huh and there's
naked people just naked people yeah no
way and they're a little uptight about
it they were you think they would thanks
they weren't as relaxed of a comedy room
as you would imagine that is up there
that's that's up there were one of the
strangest I've ever heard man I'm
actually sorry that you had to go do
that I am I am a hundred percent
apologizing on their behalf that
shouldn't happen to you you're a good
kid man
now this guy this guy it should've
happen to him
[Music]